I want to go down to the surface cuz
there are mushrooms and hey we're we're
on our side okay that's why we didn't
see him okay we okay I made the wrong
call we should have gone the other way
because the other way was towards them
well not that way is towards them okay
okay I get it now oh they're here we're
at the base oh wait are did you too yes
there are some no cuz you have cuz you
an echo have a Santa skin and I saw
Nichols and Knuckles hat is the thing
i'll usually goddamn you to just shoot
you for being that noticeable but what
the only 28 to stake what well I've to
stake now and I only ate two so that's
good be you I'm going down to one nice i
have 4 i've been here the whole there we
have mushrooms next to a roof before
yeah we do we do have the super
mushrooms that there are all those
mushrooms that we can get food from
let's do that right now good plan wash
oh ok watch out for the mobs and see if
you can get some our arrows from that
rather today it's a skeleton you have
written chanted armor i'm sitting up
here you have a shopping spots on I got
us a room this is how we're getting food
I got two more mushrooms there I got
some more dropped smaller drops smaller
drops I got six now a lot there's lots
huh I got eight I have four red mushroom
and then we'll be good six you see him
anywhere dark yep they're here hey
serious yeah dad spawn that's fun mm-hmm
let's go poop on them okay let's go
let's go and I'm out of arrows nice did
you shoot did you shoot your single one
all there yeah they're all three
strikers at all three jump down dark
come down let's go there are witches
Nick that spawn next to me
I see him come on the skeleton banners
are young down dark um I'm fight jump
down gonna be next to an area with a lot
of which is I think this homie did
they'd only saw you did a one hundred
percent saw you they didn't see me yeah
they saw you that's good watch out all
of them come in shaker all of them dark
come down here way I'm already oh gosh
all they hit me all gosh strikers golden
circle 00 which all oh my gosh I on bail
and I'm bailing on bail and I'm bailing
yup oceans yeah I got poisoned I have
half I have like no I've one heart oh
gosh oh crap they're chasing me and I
have half of a heart I've half are
either chasing me oh crap oh crap oh no
no no oh crap I can't regen health no no
are you i'm heading back to spawn dark
saved me dark you have to save me dark
dark save me saving dark dark dark dark
okay man save me please oh I can't
sprint I can't spread oh oh oh gosh oh
gosh I've half of a hard you were dark I
have a single I have a single heart dark
I need to see oh ok I have two hearts
I'm gonna let the witch attack him what
I told you I'm better with what the hell
am I supposed to do i said i was better
with ball pvp did i not slip away from
him and you pulled out your bow I was
getting mauled by animal
you know I mean Luigi there's stuff in
my pile by nexus pongo pick it off oh
yeah down here where we can't tell him
everything put you in this bush another
damn it you do not tell me this where's
the night vision I no no even see it
right axis bond yeah haha oh well we
can't help him I'm talking to him cuz
he's a cool guy I'm about to not be able
to regen health anymore well you could
kill mobs latent you guys and you are
sure Kemp the shop this one sword I
wasn't confident with the author pot so
it you bastard ow crap I'm sure dark had
food on him had like two steak health
potion and if I knew her darts body was
oh wait no I remember I remember where
it was I remember where those guys a lot
i'll be following you burn oh well screw
them oh there's a lot of skeletons
follow me there you go oh wow is Ron
forget hurry oh I can't sprint I can't
sprint good I have food in my inventory
nice and I don't think you did buy food
ah that's stupid which just ruined
everything for me I see him I see him
yeah yeah just but I I need food there's
rotten flesh do you have to I have to be
strategic you can do this man you got
this pain of arthropods sharpness one
knock back one sharpness one is a better
score than like one completely what hell
did he go the only food i have you just
at spawn two seconds ago the only food i
have is this round flesh so okay we're
so oblivious to the fact i'm watching
both of you know I Hugh is he is near
spawn I saw me out there is okay well
we're gonna do this we gonna do this oh
uh he's pooping on me he's poop he is
pooping on me yeah I can't hit him yep
oh nice I could not even hit him oh that
was good oh good if it wasn't for that
stupid which helped creeper blew up
spawn I forget opv decker like crazy
dude he didn't even have you once I I
could have like helped in the in the big
giant fight in the beginning if I had
like freaking which guys I had stricken
others to join the gal yeah hello hello
Kristen was like just dash your own
agenda and their crews you good oh I
fell by jumping off a tree and I died I
saw I was chasing you down I got hit by
a witch with poison too I got hit by a
boy i got hit by the poison which as
well and was down to half a heart so i
can really engage in the middle fight
it's not like i'm dr. tree i'm like oh
there's no way this fall is gonna kill
me you spoke too soon and then it XD
gamer was fell or fell too far there was
your
we didn't we didn't actually have a base
we just that Senate facing we uh it was
completely open sure all right well guys
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you all later peace
Oh